so last week we began the class with the
definition of cooking from the Oxford
English Dictionary who defined cooking
as the transition of food under the
application of heat you will recall that
we would cast that definition as a plot
because we're scientists and we like to
make plots and so we plotted the
temperature on on an axis and we drew a
line and we said below some critical
temperature the food is uncooked and
above that critical temperature the
three is cooked we also are able to on
that plot put different foods and so for
example here is the phase diagram of an
egg so you know that below some critical
temperature and egg is uncooked an
uncooked egg is essentially a liquid you
can sort of shake it up and down and
feel that it's a liquid inside whereas a
cooked egg when you cook it above some
critical temperature it becomes a solid
so I'm going to just flash up a couple
of different materials and show you what
the behavior looks like and then we can
try to put this all into a broader
perspective this is the phase diagram
for water there is a critical
temperature which is about zero degrees
Celsius below with which water is a
solid it's ice and there's a critical
temperature above which the water
transforms from a liquid to a gas and
you all know that that occurs at about a
hundred degrees Celsius at least if the
pressure is one atmosphere about sea
level so nitrogen has a phase behavior
that looks actually at up for all
intents and purposes a lot like that of
water at room temperature nitrogen is
actually a gas you can make nitrogen
into a liquid if you cool it enough and
it turns out that the temperature at
which nitrogen transitions from a gas to
a liquid is about minus 195 degrees
Celsius so it's very very cold if you
cool it a little more to about minus 210
degrees Celsius then nitrogen will
become a solid so here's another
material that's important for cooking
this is ethanol so ethanol of course is
something that many people like to drink
if you're enjoying or not enjoying
today's lecture with a glass of wine in
your hand then which is recommended by
the way then the then the wine of course
has some amount of ethanol that's in it
so the temperature which ethanol
transitions from being a liquid to a gas
occurs at a slightly lower temperature
than that of water it happens at about
78 degrees Celsius that's why alcohol
boils off more
quickly from a dish than water if you're
if you're ever using wine or something
to make sauces ethanol also can become a
solid and to do that you have to cool it
more than you have to cool water the
temperature which I thought becomes a
solid is about minus 114 degrees Celsius
but the point that I want you to take
away is that the general phase behavior
ethanol also is exactly like that of
water and it's exactly like that of
nitrogen it's just that the transition
temperatures are changing and in
particular looks nothing like that of an
egg